alors bonjour sa fait déjà presque
quinze ans que je travaille comme
nutritionniste c'est fou comme le temps
passe vite et là mon bus comme travail
c'est évidemment d'aider les gens à
philibert et de leur relation négative
avec leur alimentation et avec leur
poids dans ma formation
la première formation que j'ai fait et
en sexologie donc en technologie tout
notre apprentissage était en fonction de
l'être humain donc la sexualité des vues
à travers l'être humain donc dans son
intimité dans sa famille dans la
communauté dans la société si on regarde
notre sexualité pas vécu pareil en
occident qu'en orient
donc on était toujours dans l'angle de
l'être humain
ensuite de ça j'ai fait un autre
formation en nutrition et le l'aliment
l'alimentation était au coeur de notre
apprentissage donc on décortiquait la
valeur nutritive regarder quels
nutriments avait un impact plus positif
ou négatif sur notre alimentation
et comme le bac qui nous forme comme ça
c'est aussi comme ça que l'information
est transmise dans la société
donc quand j'ai terminé ces deux
formations là j'ai réalisé que mon
histoire avait aussi une un lien avec le
fait que je me suis retrouvé en
nutrition parce que moi aussi dans mon
ans dans mon adolescence j'ai vécu une
obsession par rapport à mon alimentation
et surtout par rapport à mon poids et si
à cette époque l'on m'avait demandé si
j'avais un problème par rapport à mon
alimentation avec mon poids je leur ai
répondu non parce que pour moi c'était
normal ne pas aimer mon corps donc quand
j'ai terminé je me suis dit avec comme
quelque chose qui fit est passé comme si
mes deux formations étaient comme
diamétralement opposée puis à la limite
incompatibles jusqu'à temps que je tombe
sur les travaux de lyne mongeau cette
nutritionniste qui travaillent ici au
québec depuis une trentaine d'années et
là j'ai réalisé que je pouvais comme mon
premier bac ans ex au regard des
l'alimentation à travers l'humain et de
me questionner mais le mangeur et réagit
commun donc quand on change et j'ai pas
eu de training sur le piton
donc voilà donc quand on regarde
l'alimentation et de la façon qu'on nous
lançait on a les bons aliments et les
mauvais aliments
évidemment on se dit qu'on doit manger
plus de bons aliments et le moins
possible de mauvais aliments
sauf que quand on se tourne dans l'oeil
et de regarde l'humain inévitablement on
va finir par manger les mauvais aliments
et qu'est ce qui va arriver ce moment là
la personne vous avez énormément de
culpabilité si je vous demande par
applaudissements qui dit que la fom et
le tortionnaire ce soit que vous êtes
vraiment dormi on continue qui dit que
c'est l'éclair au chocolat et sylvie qui
était la personne qui tient ces deux
aliments
évidemment la réponse est la personne
qui tient les aliments l'éclair au
chocolat c'est un éclair au chocolat la
pomme c'est une pomme la valeur qu'on va
à donner à cet aliment là c'est dans la
perception que l'on a mais d'où vient
cette perception que l'éclair au
chocolat dans cet exemple ici est
problématique c'est dans cette espèce de
pression dans lequel on vit de toujours
favoriser de plus en plus la minceur et
ça peut toujours été ainsi si on regarde
à travers les années la première mais ce
américains veuillent m6 de 21.7 pour
ceux qui sont pas à l'aise avec les mc
je vous dirais que c'est de voir à quel
point une personne n'a encore pu la
corpulence d'une personne donc si on
regarde en 1972 tout il y avait rien dit
et de 14.7 donc une énorme différence au
niveau de la de la grosseur des
mannequins la ligne rouge que je viens
de vous faire apparaître c'est un imc de
16 dans les dents les organismes et les
endroits qui travaillent en troubles
alimentaires à 16 2 et m6 on peut forcer
l'hospitalisation et lorsqu'on regarde
nos mannequins d'aujourd'hui c'est le
convoi que on a un petit problème dans
notre société
les mannequins d'aujourd'hui ont réussi
de 16 je vous dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de
personnes qui naturellement peut avoir
un imc à 16 là il
il ya une grande variété au niveau de la
corpulence mais d'avoir une
représentation comme ça de nos modèles
de skis et nous y représenter comme
étant le but avisé évidemment ça met une
énorme pression parce que la femme
moyenne elle à l'ancienneté de 23,15
donc qu'est ce qu'elle vit c'est
toujours l'impression qu'elle est trop
grosse
évidemment donc on vit dans une pression
intense pour la minceur et ce qui est
important de voir ce que maintenant on
parle plus de désir de maigrir mais bien
de peur de grossir le dernier des sm5
qui est la référence en maladie mentale
a changé son critère un des critères
pour l'anorexie pour la place d'où le
désir intense de perdre du poids pour le
transformer en peur de prendre du poids
donc ça devient comme une phobie
quand on le comprend comme une phobie
donc cette peur incroyable de grossir
parce que c'est tellement socialement
inacceptable d'être gros dans notre
société amène certaines personnes à
vivre dans cette obsession de prendre du
poids
au même titre que une personne qui a une
phobie des ponts par exemple donc si la
personne a une phobie des ponts
spontanément qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
je vous le donne en mille évitez d'aller
sur un pont sauf que quand on parle de
la phobie de prendre du poids
la personne va faire de l'évitement des
aliments en grèce en est quand on veut
traiter la phobie on va amener la
personne doucement à son rythme à être
capable d'aller sur un pont donc pour
une personne qui vit avec la phobie du
poids on va la mener tranquillement à
être capable de s'exposer aux aliments
qu'elle considère comme engrais 100 donc
là vous pouvez vous dire bon on a
quelqu'un devant nous qui nous parle de
phobie du pote ça concerne minorité de
personnes certainement pour moi c'est
parce que les statistiques nous disent
60% des personnes auraient un
comportement alimentaire considéré comme
pathologique
si c'était simplement pour perdre du
poids pour être mieux dans sa peau
clairement on n'accepterait pas de se
retrouver à avoir une vie de souffrance
de ses tantes ont pas
le pathologique on parle pas juste de
faire attention aussi on parle de
comportements alimentaires qui finissent
par diriger la vie de la personne
50% des gens se gavent 50% des gens se
privent veut dire même si ce gars vont
certainement pas en train d'avoir la
folie du poids attendez on voyait venir
95% des régimes échouent après cinq ans
pour faire partir dans l'espoir de faire
partie des 5 % 60 % vont reprendre
encore plus de poids que le poids
d'origine donc les régimes c'est
réellement une catastrophe
il est juste un peu à faire dans l'idée
de faire attention à ce qu est ce qu on
mange à tomber réellement dans
l'obsession et de l'alimentaire de son
alimentation et son poids donc c'est
important de prévenir et de réaliser est
ce que vous êtes dans la privation
si vous dites non non moi je fais juste
attention ça me prive pas moi de pas
manger le dessert
ça me prive pas moi de pas manger du
piano pendant leur mort je pense même
pas où cetto pour ma santé ou tout pour
moi de me contrôler il ya des chances
que vous soyez dans la privation est le
problème que la privation conduit
inévitablement à l'excès moi j'ai
toujours c'est comme les deux doigts de
la main si vous vous privez vous allez
tomber dans l'excès et quand on tombe
dans l'excès on s'en veut des dans
l'excès et on ne regarde que l'excès ne
regarde pas dans le fond c'est la
privation qu'il a causés et la privation
à un prix ne pas manger les aliments
qu'on préfère manger est un plaisir de
s'empêcher de manger avec plaisir parce
que quand on mange finalement ces
aliments là on vient nommément
culpabilité et quand on vit de la
culpabilité à manger mais on se dit
quand on tombe dedans ben on veut finir
le sac puis après ça va passer à
d'autres choses puis ça va être fini
alors on tombe inévitablement dans la
perte de contrôle
alors que de se donner la permission ça
diminue l'attrait dont klaus belle c'est
sûr que c'est très bon pour les autres
mais moi si je m'aime
j'ai des aliments que j'aime c'est clair
que je serais pas capable de m'arrêter
c'est évidemment dans le concept d'avoir
tellement peur de prendre du poids qui
nous empêche finalement de s'exposer
donc finalement fait vous envoyons une
solution ça peut sembler assez déprimant
ce que je vous dis en ce moment la
privation
c'est important de la voix mais c'est
important aussi de voir que les
solutions existent et ses solutions là
c'est pas dans le contrôle c'est dans la
liberté
on a un système à l'intérieur de nous
qui nous dit quand manger et qui nous
dit quand arrêter de manger souvent mes
clients me disent ah ben si je peux
avoir une lumière rouge qui allume qu'en
ce temps d'arrêter de manger pugnière
verte qui allume quand c'est le temps de
manger
ça serait donc facile je vous parie que
les gens oublient ray de la regarder
parce que le système qui gère les
signaux de faim et de satiété c'est les
mêmes qui gère votre coeur vos
battements cardiaques la fabrication de
vos hormones lui fait confiance au point
où oui pensez même pas vous vous devez
pas le matin en disant puis j'espère que
mon coeur va battre toute la journée
aujourd'hui on n'y pense même pas alors
que je vous demanderais juste pendant
cette présentation ok vous êtes
responsable des battements de votre cas
la moitié des jeunes seraient déjà
évanoui avant même la fin de la
présentation vous auriez pas attendu un
mot de ce que je vous dis trop concentré
a pas oubliés un battement cardiaque
c'est les sisters qui sait ce système
hyper performant qui gère vos signaux de
satiété
alors qu'on fait confiance on a
l'impression qu'il faut contrôler la
tête qui est vraiment paul le meilleur
le meilleur repère et la percée la leçon
quoi on peut se fier de savoir le nombre
de calories la dépense on évalue à peu
près plus apprécié on y croit comme si
on peut pas déroger de ça alors que
c'est un système commun efficace et on a
un système hyper efficace à l'intérieur
il faut juste apprendre à l'écouté puis
le signal de fin 5 signal très fort
c'est un signal de survie alors que le
signal de satiété s'est de plus avoir
faim
donc c'est plus subtil évidemment notre
vie est pas menacée si on mange trop
alors qu'est ce qu'on mange pas
suffisamment évidemment notre vie
peut-être manas sid anglais signal est
beaucoup plus fort mais quand on apprend
les
écoute et on arrive à sentir tous les
signaux dans notre corps l'autre chose
qui est important aussi quand on veut
apprendre à écouter sens les signaux de
faim et de satiété
c'est de faire confiance à son corps et
on ne peut pas contrôler notre poids
même si on essaie est ce c'est vraiment
la pilule la plus difficile à avaler
on veut croire qu'on a le contrôle sur
notre poids on veut croire qu'on peut
choisir notre poids alors que quand je
vous montrais tantôt les statistiques
95% des régimes échoue c'est pas par
manque de volonté
c'est parce que votre corps prend le
dessus et ils vous ramène au poids avant
le début de ce que lui considère comme
une famine saint système hyper évolué
pour la survie il faut absolument
apprendre à arrêter de toujours faire
croire aux corps qui est en train de
mourir parce qu'il va vous dominez il va
vous ramenez toujours au poids d'origine
et quand je vous disais la statistique
c'est qu'en plus y en a 60 pourtant
qu'ils prennent encore plus de poids que
l'origine donc cesser de croire que vous
avez contrôle sur votre poids mettez
votre énergie à écouter vos signaux de
satiété un système hyper performant qui
vous lâchera juste pas donc ensuite de
ça quand on apprend faire confiance à
son corps on peut apprendre un côté si
notre société parce que sinon ce n'est
pas encore en train de faire un régime
si vous écoutez vous si notre société
pour maigrir pour tomber dans le
contrôle et qui est du contrôle du
privations qui est du tri-nations dix
excès et ensuite passer à l'action
je peux vous dire oui mais le symbole
manger quand j'ai faim et arrêter de
manger quand je lui fait manger tout ce
que je veux la santé là dedans là je me
retrouvais malade c'est sûr d'enfance
qui est important c'est de publier que
la santé c'est quelque chose de global
il n'y a pas juste l'alimentation quand
on regarde les maladies les plus
importants dans nos sociétés c'est quoi
la dépression l'hypercholestérolémie le
diabète l'hypertension
c'est quatre maladies le sont aussi
très très associé au stress donc le
stress est aussi responsable de ces
maladies dans notre société
malheureusement quand on arrive dans le
bureau du médecin si on fait du
cholestérol jamais cerveau peut demander
est ce que vous serez c'est parce qu'on
est tous stressés dans notre société
c'est comme si on avait baissé les bras
là dessus vont dire allez voir une
nutritionniste pour changer votre
alimentation
alors que la santé c'est génétique
c'est environnementale ya plein d'autres
facteurs qui est liée à la santé que
l'alimentation s'écouter par un peu
malade
bien au contraire si on les regarde les
mangeurs intuitif ce qu'ils écoutent
leurs signaux de satiété ont l'air de
quoi eux
il m'a orientée ont tendance à maintenir
davantage leur poids ils maintiennent un
imc plus faible que la moyenne
puis en fait ce que les études ont
démontré c'est que en bas âge plus on
vieillit plus l'écart se creuse
ce qui ferait du sens considérant que
plus on fait des régimes plus on risque
de prendre du poids donc ceux qui ont un
seul sens mangeard intuitif leur imc
reste humble ayons de meilleures
habitudes alimentaires intéressant et
ont une meilleure santé physique et
psychologique
en somme ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
l'obsession que l'on a dans notre
société à vouloir toujours viser encore
plus minces conduit les gens à se priver
et la privation conduit à l'excès puis
l'on croit que c'est de notre faute si
on est tombé dans l'excès et l'on dit je
ramasse assez d'énergie ce qu'attend le
port meurent privé de nouveau et
finalement fait juste tourné dans cette
spirale dans ce cercle vicieux
donc pour sortir du cercle vicieux c'est
important de dire une bonne fois pour
toutes
les régimes la suit